[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie because flash
and arrow are on break this week this is
just going to be a bonus video for all
the big Batman and Justice League
references inside the air over shows I
also included Black Lightning stuff
because they very recently referenced
Supergirl
in air over stuff so be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos and let
me know if I left any big ones out of
this I want to know where the buy is
happening okay
and how am I supposed to track him well
you know what's billionaire vigilantes
we do love our toys I'll I can't believe
you're on board with this
those men are murderers and what's the
number of bodies between Oliver Queen
and Sara Lance what they do what I do is
completely different not really John
don't you see that what I see is you
letting the man who killed my brother
roam completely free it's not freedom
it's work it's wrong
how's this very for all wall is looking
to bomb star city we need your help to
stop her
as much as I'd love to show the wall we
think of her there's just that little
matter a tick tick boom okay we got that
miniature bombs in her spines
I've have to trust me hey Laden no
dropping bodies yeah sure I take the fun
out of it no you don't really believe he
can run that fast do you well I believe
anything is possible and in a few
minutes maybe you will too I'm getting
faster faster than I've ever been and I
won
it's because lately something's chasing
me I know what it is that's stalking me
it's my past it's getting closer and as
fast as I am I can't help but feel like
my past has almost caught up with me I
have to say I'm really digging the
brighter right suit and the white on the
symbol that's dope how'd you find me the
world she's small there's something like
Oliver we need to disappear
Showtime
what's up see you got my message that
light was perfect me want you think of
them no I think I saw it in a comic book
somewhere ironhide's can hold people
like you now you know that right you
think I'm one of those metahuman freaks
if I had powers you don't think I would
have used them get away from you
December 2013 where were you why answer
the damn question where were you
Blackgate penitentiary oh you don't
believe me check your records Timmy I
need you to confirm something for me
overwatch ROTC excuse me
well I thought that it was time you got
a code name
[Music]
let's take it
show yourself
[Music]
my masks were only big another city
I've seen darker days I've seen men of
steel die and dark nights fall and even
then I accomplished my mission no matter
what
how is awesome
we're moving back to Gotham situation
Guardian seems to be one step ahead that
screams sidekick sidekick okay so if
this guy actually had a number two I
think they would actually be more eats
my cousin worked with a vigilante ones
Cotton's of gadgets lots of demons I
mean vigilantes are nuts maybe you are
just afraid of the competition I'm sure
she was in Shaa yeah but it's bigger
than knights it's happening a lot so
people see this big guy this scary mask
and they freak out
they're run away just like Clark's
friend oh you mean I feel like they're
more frenemies what is this place Isis
hold halt hanger thing that STAR Labs
owns hurt I guess I own it you should do
something with it
in the Great Hall of the Justice League
there are assembled the world's four
greatest heroes created from the cosmic
legends of the universe guys my god I
thought something happened to you guys
to face told me you guys were dead okay
gypsy gypsy yeah but you don't know what
you don't know and underneath all this
red beautiful life built in
self-repairing armor nano liquid
circuitry full spectrum scanning and a
whole bunch of other big words chief
among them tell you two things both of
which you probably already know first
this is important I am NOT the green
arrow number two
photos can be doctored they could have
put Bruce Wayne's head on that body as
Bruce Wayne left Gotham to hang out in
Star City recently no oh the camp how do
you feel about the name bit by bit
it sounds like us to come from the
eighties great that's like really not
what we're going for
can you stand down I just needed to get
your attention you're hard man to find
you ever consider a website maybe a
spotlight in this guy a big silhouette
of an arrow what do you want why amen
new team arrows kicking ass you know
what I really have to say that I think
we should change our name what do you
guys think about the outsiders ooh I
think there's a really awesome book and
it's a grace
what are you reading the outsiders it's
not my thing
yeah if you're reading about genetic
mutations for fun maybe it should be I
mean this is nerd bait young folks with
outsize powers traveling the world
knocking bad guys on their asses and
then there are the costumes oh I do love
a costume I know exactly what you're
going through
well not unless you came in here to tell
me you're vixen you didn't right buster
no I'm kidding it's not funny I'm sorry
no I'm not vixen or Supergirl
just mom so as of right now those are
just the biggest ones but I think the
reason Black Lightning is name dropping
stuff like Supergirl the air over stuff
is just because they'll eventually
probably find some way to cross over
it's just the showrunner this first
season didn't want to have to deal with
any of the story that those other air
over shows are dealing with so leave all
your flash arrow bonus video requests in
the comments below they'll be more flash
later this week obviously a whole bunch
of Marvel infinity war stuff too don't
forget the Krypton episode one is
dropping tomorrow night on Syfy network
I'll do a video for it after it airs
I'll be giving away Legion rings when I
do those videos so just look out for
that click here for brand new flash and
click here for that special Krypton
Superman episode thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight